no major bombshells in these minutes on
the feds future course but more insight
into the debate around the table and
issues Janet Yellen and colleagues were
grappling with back at that October
meeting remember that was the meeting
when the economy they acknowledged
improvements in the economy they decided
to end their bond buying program but
they also decided to maintain their
pledge to keep rates low for a
considerable period the minutes reveal
some did want to eliminate the
considerable period language altogether
but in the end the minutes say all but
one member agreed that the committee
should reiterate the expectation that it
likely would be appropriate to maintain
the current target range for the federal
funds rate for considerable time
following the end of the asset purchase
program in October the one member
thought that the committee should
instead strengthen the forward guidance
in order to underscore the committee's
commitment to its two percent inflation
objective Narayana Kocherlakota of
course being the lone dissenting voice
in October falling inflation was on the
mind of fed policymakers in October the
minute suggest that most continue to
expect it would eventually move back to
their two percent target but they needed
to keep an eye on inflation going
forward many participants the minutes
say observe that the committee should
remain attentive to evidence of a
possible downward shift in longer-term
inflation expectations some of them
noted that if such an outcome occurred
it would be even more worrisome if
growth faltered now fed policymakers at
this meeting mark also discussed the
gyrations and financial markets have
played out in the weeks before the days
before but they decided not to mention
those worries in their statement the
same was true about weakness overseas
quote a couple of members suggested
including language in the statement
indicating that recent foreign economic
developments had increased uncertainty
ur had boosted downside risk to the US
economic outlook of participants
generally judged that such wording would
suggest greater pessimism about the
economic outlook than they thought
appropriate in the end mark they decided
to leave that out of their statement the
bottom line in the minutes as we've
heard from them publicly that economic
data is going to determine the future
course of rates and the eventual liftoff
for the Fed when it comes to interest
rates back to you and Peter though I
guess the big meeting will be next month
will be December and we're also going to
have
end of the year press conference from
the Fed chair Janet Yellen as well we
will hear from Janet Yellen and
undoubtedly they've been gearing up for
that in mark two minutes made clear they
are still grappling with communication
issues and they all seem to acknowledge
they agree on one thing it's going to be
hard for them to communicate their way
forward but that's what they're dealing
with directly right now